2024 is elected,
some elections
are already from 16
that is
we may have a say
therefore here my
Election Highlights 2024
we start
February 11
directly with the
Repetition of the federal election
in Berlin
so much went wrong back then
that the choice
in some districts
must be repeated
and it does not matter by the way
whether you at that time already
were allowed to vote
Who on the day of re-election
18 is
may participate
continues on 09 June
with the election to the
European Parliament
with which you can now also already
may vote at 16
and so that you do not
must go to the polling station
find in many federal states
the same day
still local elections take place
on 01 September
will then be the state parliament
in Saxony and Thuringia
there you may
participate from 18
and on September 22
in the state election in Brandenburg
lies the voting age
already at 16
sends the video
to your Friends
so that they do not miss a choice!